when i was a kid
guys like me were brought up to follow
coach hey
jerkle
[Music]
what'd you say what
antonio soprano
i wonder if i can talk to you alone for
a moment mr soprano
on the basis of the sanford binet he's
high iq
you can't prove it by me he's got a d
plus average
well he doesn't apply himself but he is
smart
the results tell us he's a leader
ankle dick
[Music]
growing up with the family
takes a toll maybe an ambassador to
england no pranks you're my nephew
i want to do whatever i can to help you
my gift to you
i want to go to college i can't get
caught with [ __ ] like this
look you take the speakers right at the
same time you say to yourself
it's the last time i've ever steal
something it's that simple
let me go talk to him he only listens to
dickie
i gotta do something about dickie
matasani
maybe some of the things you do
aren't god's favor
you lead by example we'll make the right
decision this kid's got what it takes
as far as your nephew goes
i'm listening stay out of his life
[Music]
you